yeah something affected him for sure  um frowning again now is Neiman shouting  through the door  this last decision however means the  game is not going to last too much  longer we will see a draw black want the  pawn back but the Queens came off and  now everything's just gonna get traded  off  and uh in the end we'll see King of Porn  end game black will go Pawn up but a  simple draw this one you need to know  you need to know where to put the white  king but we'll see the end the Game  ending stalemate just a few more moves  there's nowhere to break through and  there we go the players race forward and  it is a draw it is a draw that means  Magnus Carlsen is still in the lead in  the match against slavon aronian levonne  was not able to strike back in this game  but he still has two rapid games to make  that comeback and potentially take it to  Blitz tie breaks  he's hitching his head Lavon aronian  what can he do to be the world champion  Magnus Carlsen